here's another example of trolling
i was making jokes about ron paul he
just had a stroke
right and someone came at me and they're
like oh blah blah blah
you know you're ugly i hope you have a
stroke i hope you're in the hospital and
i just go i just did have a stroke on
your mom's face
so they came at me yeah and now they got
put in their place
with a subpar um i mean that wasn't
clever
you weren't you weren't clever not
particularly no well one of your
things you do which is interesting i
mean i give you props
in a sense is you're willing to go
farther than people expect you to yes
that's fun
yeah in fact i'll probably edit out like
half of this podcast because the the
thing you did which she kept in
i should mention is michaela peterson
now has a podcast which is
nice i guess was it on her podcast she
wasn't mine she was on yours
we did both but this is when you're
referring to when she was on mine she
was on yeah right
and you went right for the uh
so i'll tell you what it was you don't
have to paraphrase so i opened up i say
you know she's jordan peterson's dad and
as many people know george
sorry he's her dad yeah she's had a long
issue with uh substance addiction and i
said to her
you're you know you're most famous for
being you know jordan peterson's
daughter
you know many people he's changed so
many lives around the world he's and
he's been such an enormous influence
to me personally that i've started
taking benzodiazepines recreationally
and she's like oh my god michael is so
horrible
yeah you because you pulled me in with
this because you're talking i mean you
know
because he's going through a rough time
now she's going through
just everything was just you pulled me
in emotionally i was
like this is going to be the sweet mic
it is going to be just this wonderful
and then just bam so that's that's
that's that was uh props to you on that
it wasn't
whatever that is that is an art form uh
when done
well it can be taken too far my
criticism is that
that feels too good for some people
what do you mean uh for oh they're too
happy being irreverent because
to show that they don't care but
anything that's another form of cynicism
though right
so i if you because you think it's
possible to be a troll
and still be the live life
to its highest ideal in the camus sense
i try
that's kind of my ideal i i believe
it's not i it becomes a drug
i feel like that takes you like i think
love ultimately is
the way to experience like every moment
of every day
you don't think that was an expression
of i honestly think
let's let's let's split hairs here
because i think there's something of use
here
i do think that me i'm
me being able to make her laugh about
this year of hell
she was in yeah does create an element
of love and connection between me and
her
yeah but i know she would say that
yes it wasn't that it was
what you said in combination with the
sweetness everywhere else
the kindness it's a very subtle thing
but like
it's like some of the deepest
connections we have with others is when
we
like mock them lovingly or yes that's
correct
but like there is stuff
there's kindness around that yeah it's
not in words but in life of course
subtle things because it creates an
error familiarity
being familial like we're through this
together like it's yeah
yeah that's missing that's very
difficult to do on the internet
i agree with you i agree with you that's
why my
like my general approach on the internet
is to be uh some more like simple
less witty and more like
dumbly loving but that's not your core
competency being witty
uh me yeah but i i could be woody you
can be but i'm saying that's not your
core company so i'm just saying you're
bad at it but i'm saying that's not
where you go
like organically especially with
strangers
i just feel like nobody's core
competence on the internet
is uh i guess if you want to bring love
to the world nobody's core competence
is given the current platforms nobody's
core competence
is whit it's very difficult to be witty
on the internet
without while still communicating
kindness like
i'll give you another example in the
same way that you can in physical space
i'll give you another example someone
um came at me and they were like they
gave me a donation
people do this all the time and they go
oh um
like i started reading your books
because of my wife and you know now
we watch her shows together i keep up
the good work and i go
what does her boyfriend think so that is
an example of wit and love because that
person
feels seen i'm acknowledging them yeah
i'm also making a joke at their expense
we know it's a joke
so i think you have a point language is
often used in non-literal ways to cue
emotional and connectivity it's
difficult but you it's very difficult
what you've done is is difficult to
accomplish but you've done it well i
mean
you do like you did you do been doing
these live streams which are nice that
people give you a bunch of money and
donations and stuff
and then you you'll often like make fun
of certain aspects of their questions
and so yeah but it's so it's always long
that's not from love that is genuine
annoyance because they ask me some
really dumb questions but they're still
underlying it's not even like there's a
kind
person under this that's being
communicated
that's interesting but i don't know if i
get that from your twitter
i i know i get that from the video the
something about the face something about
like
yeah of course it's much harder the more
the more data yeah the more easy it is
to convey
emotion and subtlety absolutely if you
only have literally black and white
letters it's gonna be or whatever white
and black if you have night mode
it's gonna be a very different it's much
more limited information
yeah but this is the fundamental thing
is like
let's here's another example like if
they had access to my face like a lot of
times some people don't know who i am
and they come at me call me a nazi
anti-semite right and i start talking
about the jews
and just how terrible the jews are now
all my audience knows i'm jewish that i
went to shiva so they're sitting there
laughing because this person is making
ass to themselves
that person has no idea but if there was
video
then they would be like okay wait a
minute something yeah yeah something's
up
you